it is great to be joined today by drew
Penrose who heads the law and policy
department at fair vote he contributes
to work around ranked choice voting
primary elections election
administration and the Voting Rights Act
drew great to talk to you today great to
be on so let's start talking a little
bit about ranked choice voting this is
something that's a significant interest
to my audience first for people who's
who have not yet been introduced to this
concept talk a little bit about
generally how ranked choice voting works
and then we can dig into some of the
specific versions of it absolutely so
rank choice voting is simple you are
allowed to vote for your first choice
just like you do now but in addition to
that you can rank back up choices in
order of preference so if I can't get my
first choice here's my second choice
here's my third choice and so on as many
as you want to rank until you have no
opinion anymore if a candidates able to
get a majority just of those first
choices they'll win just like any other
election but if no candidate has more
than half of the votes in that first
round you eliminate the candidate in the
last place and if your favorite
candidate is eliminated then your vote
instantly counts for your second choice
your backup candidate and you just
repeat that process until a candidate is
able to win with a majority of the vote
so that way more people are able to
participate there's no talk about
spoilers or split votes or plurality
outcomes you get strong winners more
positive campaigns really a pretty big
impact for what is at its heart are
pretty simple small change yeah so let's
talk a little bit about the reasons that
so the advantages to such a system you
talked about the the spoiler effect
would be eliminated because people can
say well you know if I align more with
someone who's outside of the democratic
or Republican Party they might be my
primary choice but I don't have to worry
that I'm going to be effectively helping
the candidate I most disagree with to
win by virtue of supporting this this
other candidate what are some of the
other advantages to such a system so it
allows more candidates to participate
not only so you you emphasize there when
you talked about the spoiler issue the
ability of voters to vote honestly and
that is for
voters the probably the clearest benefit
that you have if you have independent
candidates and candidates from the two
major parties you don't need to think
well do these independents really have a
chance you can just honestly rank rank
the candidates an order of choice
there's a corollary benefit which is
from sort of the candidate or public
side that more candidates are able to
participate without being called
spoilers so if you have a positive
vision for your community and you want
to run for office the thing you don't
need to worry about anymore is whether
you're gonna take votes away from
somebody that you'd like to see when if
you can't that just goes out the window
so as a result you have more inclusive
campaigns already by virtue of having
more candidates able to run so now when
we go yeah I was just gonna say when
when they're out campaigning that
changes things as well because when
you're campaigning you not only want to
earn as many first choices as you can
but you want to make sure that if you
run into a voter who favors one of your
opponents that they're gonna rank you
second so you don't ignore anybody your
incentives are to reach out positively
to as many voters as you can it really
helps to ensure that the ultimate winner
is likely to be somebody that has talked
to a lot more voters than they would
under the current system let's talk
about some of the criticisms that exist
of at least some iterations of what
we're talking about one is the the
possibility that the eventual winner may
not actually have been anybody's first
choice and that that is inherently
problematic some would argue because you
altima tough somebody you have somebody
who has been elected despite not having
been the the sort of ideal candidate for
any of the voters and that that brings
with it problems which versions are
susceptible to that how can you tweak
the system to prevent that from being a
possibility yeah so the system that we
just call ranked choice voting the one
that I described earlier that's not a
mathematical possibility you look at the
first choices initially and if nobody
has a majority of the first choices then
you're going to eliminate the candidates
with the fewest first choices so if a
candidate is
able to attract that kind of core
support they'll be eliminated early in
the count so there's no way that a
candidate can win without achieving that
substantial level of first choices and
and historically we have seen there's
now been you know hundreds of
rank-choice voting elections at the
local level across the California Bay
Area and here in Maryland and other
cities in Minnesota and what we see is
that the candidate who leads in first
choices usually goes on to win I mean if
they're able to attract majority support
they're probably doing pretty well in
first choices as well
sometimes the candidate and second goes
on to in second in first choices goes on
to win after some sort of vote split is
resolved and in exactly one election out
of the hundreds that have taken place a
candidate and third has won that's it no
candidate in fourth or later has ever
gone on to win an election under that
method the methods that do make that
possible are more esoteric sort of more
theoretical systems so for example the
class of voting methods that are called
condor same methods where you actually
compare who you know who is this
candidate beating who are they ranked
higher than and if there's a candidate
that is ranked higher than every other
candidate under every possible iteration
then that can that it always wins
it's used in some university elections
but it's not used in any public
elections anywhere in the world that
system does make it possible for a
candidate to win by essentially being
every voter second choice probably one
of the reasons that it's been difficult
to get it adopted but the Instant Runoff
form that I described does not have that
problem at all okay good work out we're
going through these one by one and I I'm
liking this so here another common
argument is that in some way there's a
violation of one-person one-vote when
you have a ranked choice system this is
a very common one that I hear when I
talk about it and the idea being you're
sort of voting for more than one person
in this ranked way but my my
counter-argument has been in the end in
the final tally
you're only getting one vote is that the
right way to address that criticism
that's exactly right
other ways of putting it but it sounds
like you you understand pretty clearly
what's going on here so you always only
have one vote each round of counting
your vote counts for exactly one
candidate it's never the case that your
vote is helping both your first choice
and your second choice at the same time
your vote only ever accounts for one
candidate at a time
you don't get any benefit from your
candidate being eliminated and at going
to your second choice nobody wants their
favorite candidate to be eliminated and
it's not as if you're getting two votes
whereas other people only got one vote
people generally would prefer that their
vote count for their first choice in
every round of counting and that their
first choice not be eliminated this has
been assessed by courts and courts have
come out the right way every single time
so there have been lawsuits in state
courts in Massachusetts and in Minnesota
that both came out oh and Michigan all
agreeing with that principle and the 9th
Circuit Court of Appeals coming out of a
case in San Francisco also reached the
same conclusion
following his apparent loss under ranked
choice voting Bruce Poliquin the
incumbent and congressional district 2
and Maine filed a lawsuit making this
argument and although it hasn't been
judged on the merits yet an early
decision of the court indicates that the
judge is going to come out the same way
I'm really not worried about it at the
presidential level at the federal level
could any version of these rank-choice
voting systems be put in place without
an amendment to the Constitution so you
couldn't do a national level ranked
choice voting election for president
without either an amendment to the
Constitution or some kind of agreement
among all of the states to share
rank-choice voting data those are the
only two possible ways that that could
occur States could do it for their own
elections so it is already the case that
people have more than two candidates in
the presidential election in their own
states and States don't really like the
idea of all of their electors going to a
candidate who only one you know 47 or 48
percent of the vote when there were
libertarians or greens or other
part of your independent candidates in
the race so state could do it for their
own electors right now it seems that if
you had the successful implementation of
the national the interstate popular vote
compact nationally where you get enough
states to say we will award our electors
to the candidate winning the popular
vote nationally and you could
potentially integrate into that at the
state level a rank-choice voting system
that you could actually drastically
overhaul the way that we select the
president without needing to do a thing
at the federal level I mean it's an
uphill battle but am i correctly
understanding that no that's true
what you would want to do so the
national popular vote compact is an
agreement among states to use the
national popular vote to decide who to
award their electors to yes so they need
a report of the votes from every single
state in order to do that so in order
for that to be a rank choice voting
election you would need essentially
every state to be whole conducting
rank-choice voting so that they would
have the same sort of vote total to
report however the two are not
incompatible so that is to say you could
have some states using rank choice
voting and still have the national
popular vote go into effect you would
just the states that are using ranked
choice voting would report the final
round for the for the national vote
total essentially now you could combine
that with an agreement among the states
to use rank choice voting and to pool
their rank choice voting counts together
and you could get closer and closer to a
national rank choice voting election it
would start to approximate one until you
eventually got to the point where all 50
states had adopted it and then you would
have that without just like you said
without a single action needing to be
taken by the Congress briefly drew I
wanted to touch on one other thing which
is not related specifically to rank
choice but you know we see with every
election that the focus on voter
suppression and intimidation becomes
greater and greater as we get closer to
Election Day
at which point it's often too late to
really stop some of the things that are
going on so given that we just had the
midterms very very recently what can
people be doing right now already to try
to prevent these tactics
succeeding for the 2020 election which I
know sounds like it's so far away but
you we have to start thinking about this
now what can individual voters do there
are a lot of good groups out there that
are running legislative campaigns or
initiative campaigns or filing lawsuits
to try to stop those efforts from taking
place and it is really bipartisan I mean
at the elite level it looks like there
are efforts from partisans to try to
game the system but when you see it go
to the voters for example in Florida the
measure to extend voting rights to more
people after they had completed their
prison sentences passed by like
two-to-one margin in a state that's
pretty closely divided in partisanship
so it's really a nonpartisan idea and
people should be out there promoting
that in addition you know the the
national sort of sentiment being in
favor of a greater right to vote goes
hand-in-hand with our notion that the
right to vote should absolutely be more
than just putting a piece of paper into
a box it should convey real political
power and that's really what reforms
like rank-choice voting are about so I
don't see them really as separate
categories of work at all day they
absolutely are very closely connected
drew Penrose heads the law and policy
Department at fair vote drew really
great talking to you today I appreciate
your time glad to be on thank you very
much